what does it say to you simp is somebody
like you said that puts a woman in a
pedestal yeah yeah
I don't think that's a bad thing though
okay yeah do you like Subs
I don't like the word simp I wouldn't
call him I wouldn't call my partner the
same but um
kinda okay okay
are you saying it's a good thing if your
partner puts you in a pedestal yeah yeah
interesting okay what's the question
again
what is this yeah and what is the
hardest someone has sent for you what is
a sim a guy that he puts a woman on a
pedestal for no reason especially for no
reason even if it's like the girl is not
even his girl it's just a girl but he
puts on a pedestal from day one from the
from the beginning like I'm saying some
guys they operate like that like you
know what I'm saying they just look at
women as in general as like oh your
goddesses Queens when reading truly
she's she's a human being she eats poos
does everything that we do like do you
get what I'm saying so there's that
um simply for me like uh I think it's
just like normal stuff like um because
obviously as a guy it's different girls
don't really tend to simp for guys
really like you know what I mean
um
usually
um when a woman is sent for me it's
usually like just spending money on me
when not needing to like oh do you want
me to buy do you want to do that or like
you know just going out of their way
like for instance I had one girl that
you know she would always call me oh do
you need me to drive you here do you
need me to drive you there do you know
what I'm saying and it's like bro I'm
not even I'm just chilling like you're
gonna be it's calm in it cool down but I
appreciate it though yeah I was gonna
say did you like that or no I I kind of
did but at the same time because I
didn't like her that much it kind of
became annoying so I kind of see it from
a girl's point of view when a guy is
simpian for a girl when the girl don't
really like him you're just wasting your
time because that's not gonna make the
girl like you it's gonna make the girl
use you that's all that's gonna happen
in it you know what I'm saying so that
that's my that's my take on that have
you ever stepped for a girl
like do you know what yeah honestly let
me bring them up yes and no yes and no
I'm about to speak what's wrong with
these girls they said yeah at the end of
the day all guys have simped in it all
guys I remember back in the day back in
the in the days though like how old not
no recently how old like 13 that's how
far away yeah okay so you're you're very
removed yeah oh yeah that's when you
just Disney no Aladdin all them kind of
things I just wanna I just want a nice
girl to go picnics with yeah all of them
yeah so boom now I remember one girl
like I just bought a phone case like I
just bought a phone case I was just
thinking I was walking and I saw phone
because I thought she would like that
you know and I support it for her and
them times I only have no peas you don't
say I have no money so I just bought it
and then boom like that was it like you
know what I mean but apart from that
like not really you know
yeah I'm saying not really still
yeah okay
Jess
um a Sim to me is someone who
essentially does something like goes out
of their way for someone that isn't
one deserving of it or two isn't doing
anything so if you just
sitting on the couch not doing anything
and your man's like oh I'll do this for
you I'll do that for you you just have
to sit there do nothing probably Freedom
I'll do everything for you it's just
like
huh I don't I don't I think that's a Sim
but have I ever had anyone so for me no
never not that I can think of
no no no no no one that she registers no
yeah no I'm being serious oh no no wife
no no one in the friend zone no okay
okay so you Sasha
um it's kind of like similar to it all
of y'all like what have y'all said so
like a person a simp is a person who
does for another person but like they're
not dating they're not talking you're
not married whatever
um they and they like the person could
treat them like crap but they still do
things for them they'll do it they'll do
whatever they want for them but
um as of I don't think I've ever been a
simp and I don't think anyone's ever
sent over me unless you count like one
time somebody paid for my nails but I
didn't I don't know who he was like I
just met him yeah
my nails and then that's the most though
yeah
yeah pretty much like everybody was
saying when they're a bit over the top
and um in in terms of their gestures or
like over complimenting a bit too much
and things like that and usually it's
about superficial things
um like looks and stuff and um like
they're not romantically involved
they're just you know complimenting and
I don't know want to do justice for you
um I I have probably simply for somebody
a long time ago
um but I've had somebody sent for me I
hate even saying that but um I don't
want to say it's I don't want to
embarrass him what if he's watching okay
out of respect I don't know but it was
um yeah like I I felt because I didn't
find him attractive and stuff I was just
like okay stop you know I I have respect
for you and I want you to maintain your
dignity to stop okay yeah that's pretty
much it
that's like the worst way to be let down
yeah because you're so nice about it but
it's like but someone said I want you to
stop so you can maintain your date today
you know you know it was it was so bad
because I didn't want to like hurt his
feelings that I was like maybe should I
just go out I was like no no
we're not gonna ask you a question can I
ask you two questions what did he do
that was like the major thing that was
simple and the second question why
didn't you find him attractive
uh okay I I didn't find him attractive
because
um uh I me as a person when I'm like
interested in a man it's not about his
job but it's it's more of like the
Hobbies like are you interested he
wasn't interested in anything he was
interested in you though
um yeah oh okay yeah but she didn't that
have been an important that that's
really what's important yeah well I'm
not a hobby
like come on it just I didn't um I
remember when he um when I asked him
like do you have like come on you must
have something right because that's like
attractive like yo he has another yeah
you know he's more to his life and
everything like that and then um he said
oh no um when I when I get with you my
life will start and I was like wow
wow yeah so uh mad still yeah but I did
help him though I was like hey you seem
like you're interested in this why don't
you go and then I kind of just was you
was you distracted him was he physically
attracted to him
um
I mean he wasn't terrible but because
it's more like the character thing
because because a guy can be average but
when he has a character he's just like
wow
um and I yeah so you did find him
attractive no I I didn't he didn't so
because he was missing that element no
okay no that's yeah anyway no because
they're they're gonna be there can be
some good looking guys but if they're
just like yeah and personality you're
like so tender it's a waste of looks
yeah so that he left so it was it his
personality or his hobbies that turned
you off no but it's personality and it's
like his lack of Hobbies is because of
his personalities like kind of just like
oh
okay that makes sense yeah I mean what
what goodies looks
I mean you can have good looking
children at the
I have no Hobbies no the kids will have
hobbies just the guy won't yeah yeah
I don't know if he wants to America as
long as he makes money it doesn't matter
no
character
all right let me ask you basically let
me ask you another question yeah so your
ex-boyfriend the guy that you did get in
a relationship with what was his Hobbies
but I have an ex-boyfriend oh fair
enough oh okay yeah fair enough
um I think I thought you said you simp
for someone earlier oh yeah yeah but I
wasn't like oh it was a boyfriend yeah
yeah at home I don't want to get into
that I was really young okay yeah
as many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible